hoe kun je aantonen dat je het urencriterium
van 1.225 uur hebt gehaald
daar Ben je vrij in
als er bij 1 controle van de belastingdienst
maar controleerbaar is
zo kun je dat laten zien door middel van je agenda
je e mails je facturatie
je urenregistratie app of excel bestand
als het dus maar controleerbaar is
hierbij tellen alle uren mee
dus niet alleen de uren die je kunt factureren
aan klanten declarabele uren
maar ook je niet declarabele uren
denk aan uren voor administratie
marketing
reistijd of acquisitie
mag je stoppen met het bijhouden van je uren
als je 1225 uren hebt behaald
ja dat mag daar Ben je ook vrij in
uh vaak zie je wel dat de bijhouden van uren schrijven
en dan zo in zit dat je dan toch maar blijft doen
ook zijn de uren van 1 heel jaar 1 mooie input
van analyses die je kunt doen voor je onderneming